Okay,
so the question is why don't,
why do people pursue rewards that don't
produce this resonance?
They don't have a value hierarchy,
so pleasure island.
It's a good example.
Those kids that were brought there were
lost so they didn't.
They didn't have anywhere to go.
They didn't have an identity,
so they default to local pleasure and
that's better than none.
Although the problem with local
pleasure,
while as the narrative made clear,
is that you better look out if you're
impulsive because it's going to kick
back on Newhart,
and the reason is you're only
considering the immediate timeframe,
and the problem is,
is that things propagate across all the
timeframes and so just because something
works really well,
this second,
cocaine for example,
doesn't mean that it's a tenable
solution to the class of all problems.
So usually often people pursue local
pleasure because that's the best they
can imagine.
It's the best they've been taught.
They don't see another alternative.
So it could be ignorance,
it can be they don't want to adopt the
responsibility because part of the
problem with working at every level of
the hierarchy simultaneously is that
it's,
well,
it's like dancing to a very complex
waltz,
let's say.
You have to be paying attention to a
very large number of things
simultaneously and doing things right.
It requires responsibility.
And so you know,
that's.
It's a pain.
It's a weight.
Part of the reason people drink alcohol
is to get rid of their responsibility.
I mean,
that's what you know,
you hear people drink because they have
problems.
It's like,
yeah,
no.
Some people drink because they're
anxious and alcoholics drink because
they're in withdrawal.
But young people drink because they're
sick and tired of being responsible
because it's annoying.
It's like,
so I'll drink enough.
I won't care about the medium to
longterm consequences because alcohol,
that's exactly what alcohol does.
It doesn't make you ignorant of the
medium to longterm consequences,
but it makes you not care about them.
And partly it's because it dampens
anxiety.
So it dampens anxiety,
leaves your positive emotion circuits
intact.
So then you can go out there and do
stupid,
fun things and that's like,
that's a party really.
Let's go do stupid fun things.
That's a party.
But the medium to longterm consequences
are.
It's risky.
It doesn't mean you shouldn't do it,
but it's risky.
So yeah,
they don't know better.
That's the answer I would say.
So.